les opérateurs n'exploite qu'une partie
de la forêt
en cours principalement pour le bois de
sciage et on utilise les résidus de
sciage pour produire de la pâte à papier
mais une fraction importante de la
ressource et laissé sur place
parfois c'est que les essences sont
inintéressantes comme l'être et le
bouleau blanc par exemple
tantôt c'est simplement parce que le
bois ne rencontre pas les standards de
qualité trop sec trop petit fissure est
pourri affecté par des champignons ou
des insectes
cette catégorie peu attrayante pour
l'industrie on la surnomme le bois mal
aimé depuis plus longtemps ont été
dépassés par ty ar blossé ablon les
laisse en forêt vu qu'on emmène
d'abondance et quelle heure on comprend
de plus en plus l'importance des
produits du bois dans la lutte aux
changements climatiques mais on se met à
les regarder différemment pour voir si
on est capable de les valoriser pour en
faire et à différents produits ici au
centre de recherche sur les matériaux
renouvelables de l'université laval
on cherche au bois mal aimé des
propriétés qui les rendront aimable aux
yeux de l'industrie
on avait l'habitude de regarder le
matériau bois pour ses propriétés
physiques mécaniques pour le voyage pour
la qualité des copeaux pour faire des
produits de la parle par exemple faire
du papier les s'agit de le regarder
autrement des propriétés qui nous
intéressait pas avant
pour voir des dons que les compositions
chimiques en cellulose hémicellulose par
exemple où le pouvoir calorifique qui va
nous permettre d'en faire par exemple
des sources de la d'énergie
deux voies de valorisation se dessine à
l'horizon d'abord celle des
biocarburants on découvre de plus en
plus les propriétés du bois des
différentes espèces des différentes
parties d'art pour voir comment on peut
les valoriser et en faire des
biocarburants par exemple des
biocarburants liquides qu'on pourrait
mettre directement dans les autos
la seconde voie de valorisation prend la
forme de planches laminé et de panneaux
qui par exemple sont fabriqués à partir
d'un mélange de fibres de bois de ciment
et de cendres cette prendre des
particules de bois les réduire en soit
en s'ébrouant très petites particules et
les coller ensemble pour en faire des
panneaux de différentes densités qui ont
différentes propriétés intéressantes par
exemple qui peuvent améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique des murs de
bâtiments qui vont avoir des propriétés
intéressant pour résister au feu ou à la
déformation par exemple aux tremblements
de terre
tout comme pour l'industrie forestière
l'exploitation des bois mal aimé sa
compagne d'enjeux écologiques et
environnementaux
on comprend mieux en mieux quelle partie
d'armes quel arbre on peut aller
récolter tout en préservant quantité
suffisante en forêt dans les écosystèmes
leproux préserver les sols où elle
habite le québec disposent déjà d'outils
d'aménagement forestier par exemple des
normes d'intervention en fonction de la
sensibilité des lieux à la récole or ces
normes conviennent parfaitement à la
partie marchande de la forêt celle qui
alimente les scieries mais très peu au
bois mal aimé donc là ça va nous
demander d'adapter nos techniques
d'inventaire forestier pour mesurer
caractérisé qualifier les arbres et les
parties d'arles qu'on ignorait avant
qu'on les sept côté donc été les les mal
aimés qu'on inventorié pas
historiquement l'industrie des pâtes et
papiers vit des moments difficiles
certains acteurs voient dans la
valorisation du bois mal aimé une
opportunité un espoir de jours meilleurs